تسريح جماعيه للموظفين واستقالات المديرين
التنفيذيين وتراجعوا مبيعات الاعلانات
وتعليق حسابات مستخدمين بريزين تخبطت
عديده تمر بها تويتر بعد استحواذ
الملياردير الى الماسك لها ورغم كل
مشاكلها توقع اكبر المستثمرين الذين
انضموا الى صفقه ماسك لتويتر بقيمه 44
مليار دولار تحقيقه ما يصلوا من اربعه الى
خمسه اضعاف اموالها في غضون سنوات قليله
مع وجود مخاطر لهبوط محدود نسبيا شركه
عاليه كابتل الامريكيه استثمرت بقيمه 360
مليون دولار الى جانب ماسك في صفقه شراء
تويتر وتعتقد ان ماسك سيستفيدو من 229
مليون مستخدم النشط يوميا على تويتر كانوا
تاريخيا اقل من حيث الدخل هذا وتقوم حاليا
لجنه التجاره الفدراليه الامريكيه بتوسيع
دقيق في معالجه تويتر لخصوصيتي واماني
بيانات المستخدم مع موافقه الشركه بدفع
غرامه قدرها 150 مليون دولار فيما يلي
تسويه مزاعم بانه اساء استخدام المعلومات
الخاصه بحسب اللومبرج وفي جديد تسريح
موظفي تويتر تعرضت الشركه لعشرات الشكاوي
القانونيه من موظفين سابقين يقدروا عددهم
بمئه متهمين الشركه بارتكا بانتهاكات
قانونيه مختلفه بما في ذلك استهداف النساء
وعدم دفع تعويضات الفصل الموعوده وانهاء
العمل بشكل غير قانوني للموظفين الذين
كانوا في اجازه طبيه او ابويه علاوه على
هذه التطورات القانونيه يشارك حاليا
الملياردير تنفيذي في بحث طويل الامل عن
رئيس تنفيذي جديد لتويتر وهو منصب قال انه
لا يريده احد حقا وفق قوله رشه